[Music]
i know that you have your family you
have is this right you have two children
i have uh two girls two girls okay six
and three yeah how's that going how are
you dating
they're
[Laughter]
it's great they're great it's a good age
my
six-year-old is uh you know really smart
and she's like she's like maybe too
smart you know one of those she's like a
worrier yeah uh and my
youngest one my
um
might
be
can you just say
no
okay
you can't not you can't i don't mean
medically i'm not saying like
i mean like
she will this is your daughter you're
talking about
let me put it this way
she will be the first one to try drugs
she's got this thing her name is uh her
name is marlo because we nailed it
[Laughter]
and uh but she never goes by marlo like
she's always she has a a whole cast of
characters uh she's either um depending
what we're watching at the time rapunzel
or uh pocahontas
or amy a teenager named amy uh she's
just making up these names and
characters
these are at least these are words
sometimes she just comes up with whole
you know another language but uh she's
uh and then there's a sadie dinus
what
she came up with the name sadie dinus
yeah which yeah it rhymes with penis
that was you gave me a that rhymes with
penis look
no i didn't
it rhymes
i just see i'm sorry i see that rhymes
with penis looks all the time in people
i just i i put that i put that on you
and i apologize
yeah it rhymes with lady penis yeah
um
[Applause]
yeah it's so nice to talk about our
children
i love getting together and chatting
about
the kids but the other character she has
is um she a little baby named a little
baby boy named
and i'll and she'll remind me like uh
like and i'll forget like i'll play uh
the theme song to pocahontas you know
when i want to rock out sure and uh
and she'll i forget and then she she
hears the song and she goes straight out
to lunch man like her eyes just
like she loses she goes into character
and i'll say oh hey marlo do you want
she goes you mean pocahontas
and
we're giving her away
[Applause]
so father's day was sunday
i collected all the goods
now i destroy it all